you can identify the problem you can
identify what's gone wrong
but it's so much harder to get to that
place of solutions and
uh you know we don't see that in this
presentation i mean it's also his
classic
barack obama understatement of you know
and i would say one party
is not as tethered to realities i mean
heron this is a hair on fire moment as i
think that you
often bring up i don't think he
understands the hair on fire moment
[Applause]
what a great show we got we have emily
compagno what a trooper
always trying to stay in shape
she laughs at it isn't that great and we
got jimmy fella
glad to see he dressed up
apparently he's uh directing a porn
after this
or he has a meeting with his parole
officer i'm not really sure
but every time i see one of his outfits
i think the circus must be back in town
here he is at his day job
wow
wow i took the boots off of that by the
way yes you still have the diaper though
and we got a newcomer casey mcdonald she
does a fox nation show
she does her fox nation show called
monsters across
america here's some of her best work
the yosemite nightcrawler is a bizarre
glowing creature that appears to have no
arms
no torso
it can't drive
he doesn't have to deal with it
now that's star material all right
to the monologue something funny is
happening to the democrats right now
they're like your dog when he chews up
your hot hunks of the bible calendar
they realize they've screwed up it's
clear on their faces
well except for pelosi's great job botox
after you're portraying the police's
murderous racists they're now faced with
a body count that would make the wuhan
lab blush
they're now out of excuses but oh they
try don't they
the president never mentioned needing
money for police to stop a
crime wave when he was selling the
american rescue plan well the president
did mention that the american rescue
plan the
state and local funding something that
was supported by the president a lot of
democrats who
supported and voted for the bill could
help ensure
local cops were kept on the beat in
communities across the country
as you know didn't receive a single
republican vote now to believe that you
need to be as dumb as the views studio
audience
the iq is an additive how can you forget
the last year when you heard crap like
this
yes i support the defund movement
because this is about the
the um investment
in our communities which have
historically been divested
not only do we need to defund but we
need to dismantle and start anew
allows us to really re-imagine what
public safety should look like one that
i'm actively engaged in
in advocacy for is the reduction of
really truly talking about the reduction
of our nypd budget and defunding
a six billion dollar nypd budget and
before you say but greg
they're just the fringe if that's true
then binds administration contains more
fringe than a cowboy suede jacket
we've got to re-examine what we're doing
with american taxpayer dollars and ask
the question are we getting the right
return on our investment
are we actually creating healthy and
safe communities
and that's a legitimate conversation and
it requires a
really critical evaluation i applaud
eric garcetti for doing what he's done
you think that's extreme for democrats
that's as middle of the road as hunter
biden's moment
before a dui right aoc
now i want to say that any amount of
harm is
unacceptable and too much but i also
want to make sure that this hysteria
you know that this doesn't drive a
hysteria and that we look at these
numbers in context
so that we can make responsible
decisions about what to
allocate um in that context
thank you professor moonbat
[Laughter]
we should defund boston university for
giving her an economics degree
now last year i got pretty emotional
about what i saw especially in my city
fewer cops on the street while releasing
violent felons onto that same street
meant more violence
more victims you didn't have to be miss
cleo to see that coming
r.i.p but to the liberal hacks
surrounded by more armed security than
the pope visiting damascus
it was a big joke democratic cities are
in chaos right now is this what you want
from joe biden and they're gonna take
your country away and they're taking
down the statues and crime is rising
oh my gosh it's so bad and again
defunding police it's like
oh i love the sigh that clip should get
old but it won't
i'm gonna play it forever it's like
chris cuomo flexing for twitter
it shall live forever board encapsulates
the sheer disdain the media has for the
people they claim to care about
remember don lemon's great investigative
look into the crime wave
if you watch a certain state tv and you
listen to conservative media you would
think that
you know entire cities are just you know
enrolled in
fights and fires and whatever we went
out had a great dinner
in new york city tonight people actually
walked up to us and said thank you for
i watch you every night i can't believe
they thought they did do a double take
at us actually
hanging out not seeing us on the tv
screen but new york city was not um uh
you know hellscape was it jackass
hey who cares about the crime i'm famous
[Laughter]
that was a special moment for don
private time with his one remaining
viewer
maybe that's why their ratings are in
free fall all of their viewers are
getting
killed but now with trump gone they can
no longer use racism to defend liberal
cities descending into violent madness
those corroded cities are still getting
worse and it's been months since trump
left
which tells you it was never his fault
to begin with he was just their excuse
and they laughed about the riots because
they knew the violence might scare
voters
into supporting biden they're like a
mobster saying to a shopkeeper
better do what i say i'd hate to see
anything happen to your storefront
window
it's funny they aren't even talking
about violent white supremacists anymore
i guess they realize the only white mobs
were liberal arts majors tearing up
portland
whose jealousy is as green as their hair
the media never bothered to question
that big lie
but now it's collapsing faster than a
human pyramid with joy behar on top
but maybe we can focus on the real
terrorists who stormed the capital yeah
after dems bailed out looters they just
sentenced the granny to over 100 hours
of community service
for standing around the capitol so
instead of playing with her grandkids
she's picking up trash on the freeway
that's justice democrat style
so let's review the root causes of all
bad things according to the democrats
it's one racism then racism
then racism when in fact the root cause
is
them them and them crime is rising
people are dying and what's the cause
liberal policies the spikes and violence
are only in cities run by liberals
if that's not cause and effect what the
hell is the dems reject law enforcement
in any actual prison time
lefty prosecutors decriminalized crime
especially property crime
they threw out bail and called it reform
so repeat offenders could repeat even
more racking up more arrests than cat on
a bender
they grew increasingly more brazen and
more violent even in daylight
daring the demoralized police to do
something but they couldn't because they
knew that democratic leaders would let
him twist in the wind
so now you're left with a befuddled
president who gets all his crime
solutions from reruns of murder she
wrote
and a defiant far-left contingent
consumed by the desire to dismantle the
world's greatest country biden is such a
mess
he even suggested cities could use
leftover covered money to hire more cops
after allowing local governments to
defund the cops
yeah and maybe we can give the leftover
masks to the criminals while they're at
it
it's good for robin banks so we got
problems
the problems are solvable unless we
continue to elect idiot democrats the
dems treat the american people
like they're groupies you'll always be
there for them when they need you but
when they no longer need you they
don't care whether you live or die
because there will always be more
groupies
as long as they can evade the gunfire
let's welcome tonight's
guests
she has the right to remain silent and
never uses it
outnumbered co-host emily companio
if jokes were a bowl of rice he'd have a
thousand
of the same one fox news radio host
jimmy fella
she's tracked terrifying creatures like
bigfoot
the jersey devil and brian kill me
host of monsters across america on fox
nation casey mcdonald
and she was made in detroit
and then recalled due to safety defects
fox's contributor cat tip
once again i am the most attractive
person on the panel
what a homely bunch right i'll take this
disgusting i can barely look at these
people they're so
homely emily good to see you
good to be seen yeah probably as i am
okay so you are
you are obviously uh were a d.a and you
so you
love to defend murderers and and rapists
and uh just criminals in general
you must be excited about the decline of
our justice system
everyone's innocent until proven guilty
except for my friends
uh but look this is what kills me about
this whole situation because we all know
obviously the democrats have been
calling for defunding since the
beginning
it's the city councils that primarily
did so unilaterally
across the west coast especially but by
the the other side of their mouth
democrats keep talking about meaningful
reform right criminal justice reform
and a lot of the times they say that it
comes in the form of federal
intervention so we've talked about the
consent decrees
those settlement agreements that courts
enter into with these
the police departments overseen by
judges right they say yes this is
exactly what is needed
it lasts years and it takes years to
demonstrate compliance
most cities are are engaged in those
agreements throughout the country
so take seattle for example who's been
in louise after
after the city council they funded the
police the judge in charge of it all
says
you've taken us back three steps you've
actually
made not only the city less safe
obviously but you've made my job harder
and you've taken back
10 years of what we've been working
toward together
so not only are the safety of citizens
eroded the police ranks have been
eroded but also those actual steps
toward meaningful reform has been
eroded too and that's all on democrats
the irony is
that the reaction to the police
in terms of reform now requires that
they have more police
which is exactly what they didn't want
exactly i summarized everything you said
in a bite-sized piece
this is why i'm the host
jimmy uh i was curious what story
what what store did you loot to get that
jacket
uh is it i'm thinking either
merry-go-round
or chess king it was actually people who
grew up in the 80s and 90s probably left
it on the street
yeah the looters go like i don't want
this it's good to see they didn't defund
the fashion police
yes their budget is still in play yeah
i'm actually starting a miami vice cover
band
we're not pretty enough to do miami so
it's jacksonville vice yes
[Laughter]
i do want to say to your point i get a
lot of questions about my boots the most
popular one is do they come in men's
and uh yes they do if anybody's
interested um
first and foremost i mean to the point
of the body administration if he really
was serious about cutting crime
he would get hunter off the street we
know that first and foremost
but america doesn't have a crime problem
it has a stupid problem
that's our problem we have people who
can fight crime they're called the
police they're good at it
they had gotten crime rates to like a
30-year low in the last decade
right but then stupid people got elected
we live in an era where people's
emotions are their facts and they got
other stupid people to follow them along
there's an old saying in the legal
profession that if you have the facts
you pound the facts if you have the
table if you have nothing you pound the
table
the democrats have been pounding the
table on racism for a year and a half
at no point if they showed us a single
solitary fact
it's disgusting like where we live in
new york you know they have these famous
walking tours
they're now called running tours because
you're getting cakes yeah yeah yeah
lace them up kids like it's bad enough
that i would become a cop except they
have this thing called a background
check so i'm not going to get in like i
couldn't become a cop in the village
people at this point
yeah but it sucks and it is it's their
fault it's stupid people our problem is
stupid people by the way
i believe the movie that you're
directing later is called pounding the
table but emily
hey the rent don't pay itself casey
welcome to the show i apologize
uh in advance uh you do a show called
monsters across america
is it the democratic party the real
monster oh my goodness
hey i mean i haven't had them on a
season yet so you're gonna have to talk
to joe escalante about that we've got a
really long waiting list
yeah um but but uh yeah we tour the
country so if you have any suggestions
you'll have to call my there's this
crazed person in like the
west side of uh of manhattan who uh owns
a small dog and vapes constantly they
call her the
the vaping widow that's the bender i'm
trying to go on
[Laughter]
well when your husband mysteriously
disappears and
go do the do the vaping widow give me
the vaping
okay what are your thoughts on uh police
in general what or what's your take on
all of this stuff
all this everything just my take on
everything yes my take on everything is
yes
yes no i think you know let the police
be police let them let them keep the
streets i mean i've been bopping all
around the country
shooting which is great but i love
shooting shooting no no sorry
no sorry uh filming filming
you'll have to speak to my lawyer oh
don't use her she talks too fast
no that's great that's great me too i'm
jersey um
where was i going oh so coming back to
new york there's this sense of
yes liveliness you're going out to eat
people don't recognize me when i go out
to eat but um
you do look over your shoulder when
you're walking and you you got to get a
handle on it and that's
that's the problem it has changed cat
hasn't it what is what's your solution
and i hate to bring up the phrase
libertarian but that's well
are yes well guess what what i wrote a
column that just came out on foxnews.com
about this very thing um and i just
really think part of the issue is this
is just an example
of the you know the democrats blaming
republicans for defund the police which
is obviously
completely ridiculous but so much of our
discourse is focusing on blaming people
for other pro
you know for problems rather than
looking for solutions because
when this first started you know having
this reckoning last summer
polls were showing that most americans
agreed that they wanted to change things
about policing but most americans
including 81 percent
of black americans wanted the same level
or more police in their neighborhoods
there was so much agreement and how do
we end up here it's because
there's no room for any nuance at all in
these discussions it's just about
political partisanship
and trying to blame other people and the
amount of imagination that it must have
taken to try to blame this on
republicans
there's a lot of wasted energy that
could have been trying to solve this
problem because it's serious and it's a
matter of life or death thank you
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else